We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. before
we get to that membership special results.
We did a membership special on January one
called our 2020 membership special and 206
people took advantage of it.
206 people in the first couple of days of
the year have signed up as new members taking
advantage of this discount.
The code is still available.
If you want to email me, I will send you the
code and uh, maybe we can even get it to 250,
206 people so far.
Okay.
Here is a color sort of equating the cult
of personality around Trump and Trump supporters
to that of those who were defending RNB, singer
R Kelly, despite credible, uh, numerous allegations
of sexual assault, uh, weird urination stuff
and holding women essentially a prisoner.
Take a listen to this call.
Hi David.
It's Russell from Alabama.
I had two things to bring to your attention.
I've noticed a slight similarity in the cultist
mindset of Donald Trump's impeachment equal
to that of our Kelly's trials.
People denied the pee tapes and the testimonies
and the phone calls and all these things.
I kind of see the same thing happened with
Donald Trump and his cult followers.
Also, this whole thing about the impeachment
would nullify his term and therefore he would
get to run again.
[inaudible]
is pretty dumb on its face because if that
were the case then when the Republicans had
the house in the Senate, wouldn't they have
simply impeached their own candidates to keep
him in for another term?
She doesn't make any sense.
Yeah, it doesn't.
So listen, first of all, uh, it's a, it's
an aggressive, uh, comparison Trump supporters
to R Kelly defenders.
Um, but it's not crazy and I appreciate you
making it.
You're, you're absolutely right that, uh,
if you could, by virtue of impeachment give
a president eligibility for an entire additional
term, you would see it strategically done
by members of the president's party.
And I think at most, um, you could argue that
if Trump was, they actually, you know, I can't
think of any way in which it makes sense.
I was going to say, if you, if you convict
Trump on impeachment and he ends up not serving
out his last year, that he could conceivably
be eligible to be vice president in the future,
and if the president died, maybe he could
serve out the remainder of someone else's
term, but even that doesn't really make sense
because you might be precluded altogether
if you're convicted on impeachment.
I don't know the answer, but it's a very crazy
thing to say.
For sure.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show,
become a member@joinedpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].